bonjour ce n'était pas la première mais
c'est comme ça moi je suis là pour
parler de la lumière éphémère telles que
celles que j'aperçois c'est à dire dans
le monde du spectacle
c'est une c'est un état d'esprit
c'est une philosophie c'est c'est avant
tout un travail qui amène au plaisir des
yeux
lorsque j'ai commencé ce métier j'étais
musicien je faisais des percussions et
puis au fil du temps j'ai organisé des
concerts toujours autour de la musique
et puis au bout de quelques années je
suis passé de l'organisation de
spectacles à la technique puisque
j'avais trouvé quand même que la lumière
pour le coup était un outil majeur pour
communiquer pour exprimer tout un tas de
choses et dans le spectacle en fait on
n'a pas de limites on now quasiment
aucune contrainte
on peut dire que on sculpte on monte on
occulte
on se sert de la lumière comme on veut
afin d'arriver finalement à nos fins et
pouvoir vous présenter à vous public une
image que l'on a dans nos têtes
essayez de faire partager une émotion au
travers de cette image là le il ya un
mot qui revient systématiquement quand
même qui m'a moins toujours perdu
profondément ému c'est la magie en fait
on a tous de la magie on nous on a tous
enfouis dans nos vies ce côté enfantin
qui fait que au travers de la lumière on
arrive à le retracer
la lumière s'éteint un vocable poétique
qui permet de de d'exprimer quelque
chose
et pour pouvoir exprimer ce que l'on
veut en lumière ça nécessite un
apprentissage d'un langage donc d'un
vocabulaire qui passe par des mots et
ses mots ce sont les outils les outils
ce sont des projecteurs c'est ce que
vous avez devant vous en illustration
c'est à dire face est simplement pour
vous expliquer très rapidement le début
de la lumière s'éteint bien sûr ça a
commencé avec des bougies
mais lorsque moi j'ai commencé on était
plus aux bougies on était des
projecteurs fixe avec un faisceau qu'on
a grandi c'est confirmé qu'on aime et
qu'on mettait sur un personnage mais il
fallait choisir la couleur l'intensité
le positionnement et c'était déjà quand
même assez fastidieux mais malgré tout
ça nous permettait de commencer ce
métier et puis l'optique a évolué et on
a ça nous a permis de pouvoir avoir des
cadreurs et donc de pouvoir y mettre des
gogos c'est ce que vous avez c'est à
dire des formes lambda géométriques ou
pas qui nous permettait d'envoyer un
effet un peu comme un tableau sur un sol
ou sur un mur techniquement on est passé
des projecteurs simple à des projecteurs
un miroir ou en fait la lumière sortait
d'une boîte à lumière à laisse réfléchir
sur un miroir et ont piloté le miroir
depuis la régie et ça nous permettait
déjà d'avoir une mobilité de la lumière
et puis on est arrivé ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est dans les projecteurs
automatiques où on dispose de toute la
palette graphique un peu comme en
peinture pour pouvoir choisir les
couleurs changer la taille du faisceau
l'orientation du faisceau et puis faire
des effets dans le ciel sur scène où on
peut imaginer ça c'était la partie un
peu technique des outils
aujourd'hui ces outils là nous
permettent de traiter des façades de
faire de l'habillage du décor dans une
ville sur un bâtiment quel qu'il soit de
manière beaucoup plus simple qu'avant et
surtout de pouvoir transformer en fait
un édifice et c'est là où la magie y
revient c'est qu'en fait ça nous permet
en un rien de temps de pouvoir projeter
des motifs et donc que sublimer un
bâtiment comme l'opéra de bordeaux par
exemple lors d'un concert mais cette on
est toujours dans un facteur temps très
particulier avec la lumière en spectacle
c'est à dire qu'en fait nous la deadline
c'est un jour un homme une heure et
après c'est fini
donc voilà on va vite on intervient on
met en oeuvre ce qu'on a préparé et puis
après on essaie de faire passer un
sentiment les concerts c'est celle là où
la lumière a le plus de dimension
vivante je dirais aujourd'hui dans le
sens où vraiment là on est dans le
partage avec les gens qui sont dans la
salle les artistes sur scène et est
aujourd'hui entre les effectué et ses
terres on arrive vraiment à sculpter et
à donner des images très précises
j'ai le souvenir d'un concert où je
faisais l'éclairage c'est un concert de
sang et clark et à ce moment là il y
avait une sonorisation qui tournait avec
l'artiste
une américaine et qui m'avait dit comme
consigne dès le départ du spectacle
c'est à dire de poser des effets de
lumière des tableaux en fonction de
chaque morceau mais de rester calme de
rester posés malgré tout la musique que
j'entendais des qui pour moi générer une
émotion forte
il y avait du groove ça bougeait donc je
ne pouvais m'empêcher que de faire
bouger mes doigts et de est de faire
bouger la lumière sur scène et à chaque
fois je le faisais en fait le public
réagissait dans la salle et se lever et
se met à danser
il se retourner systématiquement le
crier dessus en anglais c'est un pays ce
topic
et puis je lui disais oui j'ai arrêté 30
minutes après le recommencer ça a été
comme ça tout le show je me suis pas
fait une amie mais bon j'étais content -
et finalement public était très content
aussi
voilà c'était juste un souvenir mais
qu'ils étaient
qui m'a fait prendre conscience
peut-être vraiment à ce moment-là de
l'importance de l'énergie que la lumière
vivante on va dire mobile en mouvement
on pouvait générer chez les gens c'est à
dire en fait un accompagnement
véritablement de d'une manière de
mouvoir d'une manière de bouger de
ressenti au delà de la musique ça
fonctionne avec et c'est ça rentre en
osmose avec la musique
au delà de la technologie qu'on utilise
lors de spectacles comme des concerts il
ya aussi l'aspect plastique
c'est à dire qu'en fait la lumière c'est
la poésie
alors c'est prétentieux que de vous dire
ça comme ça mais c'est dans tous les cas
ce que je pense et c'est la poésie dans
le sens où lorsqu'on intervient sur une
installation comme le parc que vous
voyez derrière derrière moi c'est un
dans le cas du festival lyon lumière par
exemple la technologie et les basiques
ce sont des guirlandes et de la lumière
verte dans le gélatineux sur des
lampadaires
c'est très simple l'idée l'un n'est pas
d'utiliser la technologie pour en soit
ce n'est pas une fin l'idée c'est de
pouvoir transformer un endroit de le
proposer au regard des gens qui s'y
promènent de manière différente de ce
qu'ils ont l'habitude d'ivoire en
l'occurrence les lyonnais puisqu'il
s'était concerné directement pour eux la
dans le cas présent mais et puis les
badauds qui venait d'ailleurs c'est en
fait ce qu'il avait vu en plein jour le
voyez une certaine manière l'imaginé
d'une certaine manière la nuit et dans
le transformer en en faisant autre chose
et là on a pas de technologie
donc on revient à l'essentiel c'est à
dire c'est une image
autre image métiers du même dans le même
registre en fait on est vraiment là sur
un parc de la tête d'or à lyon c'est un
exemple c'est encore une fois voilà on
simule une saison au travers de la
lumière qu'on projette sur les arbres et
des objets que l'on met au sol là encore
on essaie d'amener de l'émotion est
d'amener un sentiment de froideur de
susciter des sensations de chez le
public qui souffrent qui s'y promènent
et là c'est un peu de vue que la
position des deux c'est à dire qu'en
fait là il y avait une demande qui était
de toi de travailler entre la basilique
un point haut de la ville et la
passerelle sur le rhône un point bas
fallait créer une liaison fallait
travailler sur les deux édifices et
après donc il ya des choix techniques
qui s'imposent pour pouvoir se faire
malgré tout la lumière dans
l'inconscient collectif
c'est quand même la fête et on se rend
compte toujours maintenant que on a tous
en tête l'image de la guirlande d'une
guinguette
lorsque vous allez boire un coup à
droite ou à gauche où il ya trois
guinguette qui se promènent au dessus de
vos têtes
je pense que ça nous fait tous le même
effet les lampions en asie c'est pareil
les bougies qui flotte dans les papiers
pliés colorés sur l'eau c'est la même
chose
et cet aspect là il est toujours
important de s'en souvenir et d'aller le
rechercher
ça permet d'aller recomposer un peu
comme un peintre avec une palette
d'aller chercher des couleurs et
finalement de de reproposer encore
encore des regards différents dans cette
image
le peintre hooper montre un
environnement obscur et avec une lumière
intérieure très forte qui se détache
littéralement puisque j'apprécie est ce
que j'aime beaucoup dans cette oeuvre en
fait c'est le se contracte et cette
envie que cela suscite au regard de
pouvoir pénétrer finalement danse dans
ce bar est d'aller rejoindre les gens
filles y sont voilà c'est un clin d'oeil
mais la peinture en ce sens est aussi un
vecteur de lumières très très important
là c'est une photo que j'ai eu le loisir
et la possibilité de prendre n'est pas
très longtemps et la baie d'along au
lever du jour là c'est simplement
magique
je pense qu'il sait difficile de faire
culture on est loin de la lumière
artificielle
on est loin de la lumière de ce
spectacle on est simplement dans
l'élément naturel
un lever du jour loin des bruits de la
cité des véhicules etc etc on est
ailleurs et là c'est la nature qui
reprend le dessus et qui vous emmène
tout simplement avec les brumes qui se
dégage qui vont petit à petit se
dissiper avec la journée dans cette
image
c'est aussi un souvenir personnel c'est
c'est la lumière la lumière en toscane
hélas les cette lumière la paire mais je
dirais avec les infinité de nuances de
jaune et de vert et cette brume qui va
aussi se dissiper petit à petit de
ressentir et de sentir le parfum des
oliviers hélas cette vision de la
lumière me rends contemplatif et c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire au travers de
mon travail dans la lumière de
spectacles ou d'événements c'est d'aller
pouvoir faire ressentir ce genre de
chose à ceux qui sont présents celle ci
s'était s'abolir à un coucher du soleil
tout le monde a vu des couchers du
soleil tout le monde s'extasie devant
les coucher du soleil
ici ou ailleurs dans le monde entier et
c'est normal parce que c'est magnifique
une anecdote celui ci j'étais sur les
remparts d'essaouira avec mon épouse et
mes enfants
et puis on avait assisté pendant une
demi-heure à la déclinaison du soleil et
en toute finalité
celui ci disparaît sur la ligne
d'horizon
j'applaudis et je me mets à applaudir
les enfants ma compagne et à ce moment
là les centaines et des centaines de
personnes soit les remparts
applaudissent en criant et en scandant
des bravos et des hourras il a on efface
la lumière de ce spectacle il est tout
simplement totalement naturel et
l'humain à ce moment là en partage
remercie cet élément la dame nature de
nous avoir fait vivre ça dans mon métier
on utilise la lumière pour éclairer des
artistes sur scène pour éclairer des
orateurs un conférencier pour éclairer
des dîners des espaces de réception
alors il ya le sens éclairage ou là on
est sur du fonctionnel pur et dur et
puis un sens artistique et on s'efforce
à amener un sens artistique à tout ça
pour pouvoir encore la provoquer des
émotions
cette image là vous la connaissez
certainement pour les bordelais
ce sont les quais de bordeaux avant les
grands travaux dirais-je l époque où il
y avait des corps les hangars à ce
moment là la mairie de bordeaux vous
demande tout simplement de trouver une
solution pour éclairer ce qu'on va
qualifier de promenade puisqu'à l'époque
les bordelais ne se promener pas du tout
c'était sombre et c'était je crois
l'organisation de la première fête dure
il s'agissait là de trouver dans le pari
en fait un il s'agissait de trouver le
moyen de mettre de la lumière sur tout
sur toute une zone tout en longueur
voilà sur laquelle n'y avait aucun point
au pas de lampadaires et du tout et puis
sur laquelle des milliers de personnes
est allée se promener dans un
environnement relativement dangereux
bord du fleuve dont fait absolument
trouver la lumière est là j'ai proposé
de créer un dispositif simple 1 basée
sur deux voiles pour rappeler
symboliquement les bateaux qui
permettait d'être d'avoir une lumière
réfléchissantes au travers des voiles en
soirée d'avoir un point haut pour y
mettre malgré tout quelques projecteurs
et surtout c'est qu'en journée ces
voiles là avaient leur propre vie donc
en fait un objet qu'il permettait
finalement de faire la lumière quand
j'en avais besoin
cet objet là avait sa propre oeil en
journée et là encore lorsque les gens se
sont promenés pour la première fois
cette manière là sur l'été et que j'ai
entendu des réactions d étonnement des
uns des autres
des sourires des regards pétillants des
étincelles dans les yeux je pense que
j'avais fait mon job
l'imaginaire que l'on a tous en nous
varie selon chacun d'entre nous et le
lorsqu'on travaille sur des bâtiments
encore une fois en éphémère puisqu'en
fait à ce moment-là on peut tout se
permettre
je dirais qu'en fait nous on n'a pas de
contrainte de pollution lumineuse on n'a
pas de contrainte d'éblouissement on n'a
pas de contrainte de visibilité du long
terme
on n'a aucune contrainte seul contrainte
fonds d'aidé budgétaire met donc on est
face à nous mêmes et on fait ce qu'on
veut
à une époque on utilisait des
projecteurs diapositives qui s'appelait
des pagny et qui permettait de projeter
des grands diapositives
alors au début on plaque et des images
sur une façade et puis on était content
après on se dit il faut que ça bouge ces
images là on les a superposé on a mis
des machines les unes à côté des autres
on a fait passer des images d'un instant
sans même force des images dans l'autre
et on a créé du mouvement et petit à
petit ça nous a permis d'évoluer
largement et de passer ensuite à une
technique qui aujourd'hui est beaucoup
plus poussée sophistiqué qui est celle
de la vidéo mais qui est totalement
imbriqués à la lumière aujourd'hui on
fait de la lumière au travers de la
vidéo
là vous allez voir un petit sujet vidéo
qui ne dure pas longtemps et qui est une
réalisation qu'on a fait 15 jours que je
vous laisse découvrir et je vous
reprocherai prend la parole dans
quelques minutes
mais pas que en fait on se sert du
bâtiment vraiment comme d'un écran mais
aussi en même temps évidemment on tient
compte au millimètre près de cet écran
là puisqu'en fait toutes les formes qui
apparaissent à l'image ont été calculés
formaté le bâtiment a été modélisé en
informatique et ça nous permet
aujourd'hui d'aller bien plus loin que
simplement qu'avec la projection de
lumière
légis
nous permet de sus de créer des images
totalement
sorti de nos imaginaires respectifs où
l'on se fait vraiment plaisir quand on a
carte blanche comme ici
et puis ça vaut ça nous permet surtout
aller les chercher aussi chez vous
public est à celle là cette magie peu
lors que l'on aime a suscité en
pratiquant le métier que je fais
et
voilà ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
avec la lumière mais c'est de la vidéo
pour finir rapidement parce que je pense
que j'ai un peu dépassé le temps mais
pour finir j'ai juste vous relater une
situation qui du vécu c'est à dire qu'à
contrario des technologies des images
que j'ai pu vous montrer jusqu'à
maintenant je me suis retrouvé un jour
dans une situation où j'avais une amie
qui était commissaire d'une exposition
dans les jardins de l'orangerie dans
l'orangé le jardin du luxembourg et qui
demandent de faire la scénographie avec
elle et puis à ce moment là je me suis
dit super challenge super défi de la
lumière de l'art contemporain et de la
scéno dans un espace c'est superbe
ok sauf que elle ne m'avait pas dit
qu'elle ne voulait elle voulait que je
ne fasse pas de lumière en fait elle
voulait que je fasse de la scéno mais
que je fasse une mise en lumière avec la
lumière qui rentrait par le au delà de
l'orangerie qui était une serre et là il
a fallu en tant que quart hagist en fait
je tienne compte uniquement de la
lumière naturelle et que j'arrive à
disposer et a proposé aux artistes
un point de vue de leurs toiles de leurs
sculptures d'une certaine manière dans
un espace donné avec la lumière du jour
comme quoi lorsqu'on peut aller parfois
très loin avec un outil une langue un
langage un mode d'expression
régulièrement une situation qui nous
ramène de l'autre côté qui nous rappelle
l'essentiel c'est à dire la lumière du
jour
merci à tous